[Music]
so here we go
we're going to do my first reaction
video on the show it's the encanto about
the mirabelle and a fight
all right uh
nate douglas roll it up what is going on
it's okay everything's we're gonna save
the miracle the magic what are you
talking about look at our home look at
your sister please just isabella wasn't
happy of course she's unhappy you ruined
her proposal no she needed me to ruin
her proposal and then we did all this
and the candle burn brighter and the
crap that's why i'm in the vision i'm
saving the miracle you have to stop
mirabelle
the crack started with you
bruno left because of you
luis is losing her powers isabella's out
of control because of you i don't know
why you weren't giving a gift but it is
not an excuse for you to hurt this
family
okay stop it right there
so
they're having two different
conversations here
mirabelle that's that's the young
young woman right
mirabelle is simply saying
can you see me
can you see the good
that i'm bringing to our home
and abuela is saying grandmother is
saying
you are in service to the bigger machine
here the facade is more important
than
what you your little feelings what you
think
do you see me versus
know your place here what's one of the
most common family like they're just
talking past each other
and they're both of their hearts are
exploding in opposite directions even
though they're staring each other in the
eye all right hit play
[Music]
i will never
be good enough for you
will i
no matter how
hard i try
[Music]
no matter how hard
any of us tries
lisa will never be strong enough isa
won't be perfect enough all right hit
pause here
okay common move i was i was all team
mirabelle
but now she's triangulating people now
she's dragging other family members into
the formation of her boundaries now how
old is she in this movie
is she like twenty one yeah
early twenties no
she's seven i don't wanna be like suck
it up seven-year-old if you're 21 22
this is where like there's this this is
like the revelation right this is when
you start to realize oh my mom's always
gonna be like this my dad will never say
the words i'm proud of you my
husband or boyfriend will never
hear my needs right these are these
moments but it's then when you go and my
my girlfriend she sees it too
or
yeah and my dad and now i'm looping
everybody in to the formation of my
boundary and that's a mess when you
start to have these realizations that oh
this is going to be the way this always
you are going to be the way you always
are i'm the one who's got to change here
what i'd love people to do is to say
these are my boundaries i'm going to use
i statements here this is for me
my sister can watch this happen and then
she can choose to have her own
boundaries my brother can too this is
about me okay hit play now i'm all into
this family because you only saw the
worst in it
didn't care
[Music]
you're the one that doesn't care
you are the one breaking our whole cute
miracle is dying because of you
[Laughter]
look at that
okay
so
ah this is when things were going well
and then it turns
hollywood the face so if you're
listening to this
grandmother just had the face right the
right like the face of oh no you're
right
for the last 50 years i've excluded my
son i've
kept my thumb over everybody
this doesn't happen in reality
very very rare and it doesn't happen
with the music swelling and there's this
great big thing this idea like this
magic sentence i'm just going to say the
magic sentence i was working with
somebody the other day and they said i'm
just waiting for that that one
that one thing that someone's going to
say that's going to cut through it and i
finally said that thing's not coming
right so we have this picture that when
we create boundaries the music's going
to swell and we're gonna say our
boundary across the table we're gonna
come to the realization and they're
gonna go
it was me
that never happens
usually it ends with i hate you get out
of my house
or find then or i'm taking you out of
the will or then i'm going to start
seeing somebody else right we wait for
this fantasy moment this perfect
catharsis and it doesn't happen
right
this ah
so abuela's
so yo i haven't seen i've seen it but i
fell asleep halfway through with my kids
i was tired and i now i'm gonna go back
and watch it it looks amazing but
here's what's important like it sounds
like abuela created a story she got
deeply hurt and she created a story
to move this family along and the story
in the short term created a lot of
beauty and a lot of cool things and
there's a lot of things that she could
talk about when it came to her kids a
select group of her grandkids is that
right close yeah it's everybody but
mirabelle has a gift has a gift right so
right but but it comes out of this pain
right the the other
the another gift wasn't recognized to
the son right and he got kicked out
or he left or something people didn't
like his gift he was like telling people
like what was going to happen in their
lives the gift of a prophet right yeah
so they yeah prophets always get rid of
their town okay so he had this gift of
prophecy right
and abuela's heartbroken deep down she
is heartbroken and instead of
dropping her shoulders and weeping and
leaning into that grief
she created an entire system that props
herself up and the whole family up and
when you do that it inevitably crumbles
around you like i guess that's what is
that what happens here everything
crashes and and then flowers are going
to bloom at the end right is that how
that works
kind of yeah
i can just hear people going no that's
not how that goes
right i mean she's reacting out of this
trauma that she experienced when the
gift was created so everything that
she's doing now is pretty much an act of
fear of
i've lost my husband
we lost everything and this gift was
born out of this grief
so we're gonna hang on to this thing
yeah so she is like desperately hanging
on to it because she doesn't want to
lose her family again and she's pouring
all of that
into like the gift she's like we've got
this gift so we can't let it go oh okay
also she's so the the thing that kept
her alive
is gonna be the thing that crushes our
entire system right
gosh that's great so
all along yes
realizing that the thing that kept us
going the thing that got me through the
hard thing
can also turn into the thing like being
able to hide when i had an abusive dad
is gonna be the thing that
that ruins my marriage down the road the
f like um learning how to stand up for
myself and to protect my
little brother from getting abused is
going to be the thing that gets me put
in jail for violence right so these
things that help protect us early on can
be the things that ultimately and that
we create identities around but they can
be the things that ultimately drag us
under water later on
and all this goes back
the greatest gift you can give your
family and your children your kids is to
see them to love them along the way even
if that at this at the beginning they
don't look like they have gifts and for
those of you who are practicing thinking
about learning to create boundaries
there's no big music at the end there's
usually a lot of guilt and there's a lot
of exhaustion and there's tears
and it's right
you can create your boundaries it's good
there's no music that plays huh i wish
it did though anything someone should
just follow me around the boom box for
when i set a boundary and it goes
turns it up i make my heart feel good it
just doesn't doesn't happen